two weeks ago I got this surprising
email saying congratulations and
actually at the time I didn't believe
the email and I was really it was it was
too unreal and I emailed the play Magna
support staff and they told me it was
legitimate so I'm here to play magnus
carlsen in a chess game I don't know if
we'll call it playing but if I'm about
to be beaten by pectus girls in a chess
game I have a few idols and my first
idol in chats was Bobby Fischer and then
now it's Magnus Carlsen and just to meet
and it's a dream like a dream come true
when you hear about someone who becomes
Grandmaster at the age of 13 it's hard
to conceptualize what that actually is
how good they actually are at such a
young age but when you actually want to
actually happen to see you know you have
to stop being full of yourself and
realized he's kind of you know the
greatest thing that's ever happened to
Jess it's demoralizing here we're at the
Marshall chess club we've been here
since 1915 this is our hundredth year
anniversary every champion says kappa
blanka has set foot in this chess club
actually this board right here to my
left I believe every world champion says
kappa blanka has sat at this board and
now Magnus is here
hi sweetie
two years ago I lost in 17 Roos and he
plays me kind of slow-motion not on a
very fast motion do you know the lucida
position
I hope I'm world champion about ten
years I'm sure you'll be to our first
Grandmaster before that no nerves
it's just anxious to get started
I was definitely surprised by his speed
it was a little unnerving actually a lot
of pressure just came from the fact that
he was at your board so quickly
basically how it felt was like a storm
closing in on me and I can see the dark
clouds coming faster and faster and then
I was over
I would have we business here that you
can attack but now my pieces have well
developed well this experience playing
with Magnus has really taught me
something and I well first thing I
didn't know I could be wiped out so
quickly and second I've never seen a
storm coming that fat he has a persona
you know that when you play him you're
playing against the best player in the
world and just like he humbled me with
his Magnus seven and eight play he's
humbling me again the world of chess he
really is the pinnacle I knew that
before but it's different when you
actually meet someone and watch them
play you understand a lot better than if
you just flip through a game online
you